Speaking of Psychology is taking a winter break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. Last January, I talked to psychologist Josh Davis and super-recognizer Kelly Desboro about what it means to be a super-recognizer, someone with an extraordinary ability to recognize faces. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in January. Thank you for listening. Last year, we ran an episode about face blindness. People who are faceblind have trouble recognizing the faces of even their closest friends and family members. They're at one end of a spectrum of facial recognition ability, and today we're going to talk about the people at the other end of that bell curve, the super recognizers or people who never forget a face.
《心理学说》正在进行寒假休整，因此我们将重播过去我们最喜欢的剧集之一。去年一月，我采访了心理学家乔希·戴维斯和超级面孔辨识者凯利·德斯伯勒，探讨了成为超级面孔辨识者——也就是拥有非凡面孔辨识能力的人——意味着什么。希望大家喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。《心理学说》将于一月携新节目回归。感谢收听。去年，我们播出了关于脸盲症的一期节目。脸盲症患者甚至很难认出他们最亲密的朋友和家人的面孔。他们处于面孔辨识能力光谱的一端，而今天我们要聊的是正态分布曲线另一端的人，也就是超级面孔辨识者，或者说是那些过目不忘的人。
Scientists only began to study super recognizers a little over a decade ago, and since then, they've been. learned a great deal about this extraordinary ability. They've also begun to explore, together with police departments and other security organizations and businesses, how super recognizers might contribute to police investigations and other security work. So how well can super recognizers remember faces? Can they really recognize a person whom they saw for only a few minutes many years ago? Are super recognizers as good as computer facial recognition algorithms? And can you train yourself to be a super recognizer or at least improve your own facial recognition ability? Or is this something you have to be born with? Welcome to speaking of psychology, the
科学家们在十多年前才开始研究超级面孔辨识者，从那以后，他们对这种非凡的能力有了深入的了解。他们还开始与警察局以及其他安全机构和企业合作，探讨超级面孔辨识者如何为警方调查和其他安保工作做出贡献。那么，超级面孔辨识者的记忆力到底有多好？他们真的能认出一个多年前只见过几分钟的人吗？超级面孔辨识者能比得上计算机面孔辨识算法吗？你能不能通过训练让自己成为一个超级面孔辨识者，或者至少提高自己的面孔辨识能力？还是说这必须是天生带来的？欢迎收听《心理学说》，
flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Our first is Dr. Josh Davis, a professor of applied psychology at the University of Greenwich in London. Dr. Davis began his research career studying facial recognition ability and eyewitness identification. Since 2011, he has focused mainly on understanding super recognizers exceptional abilities in this area. He's developed screening tests to help better identify super recognizers, and he works with police departments and other organizations around the world to explore the ways in which super recognizers can contribute to security work.
这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。第一位是伦敦格林威治大学的应用心理学教授乔希·戴维斯博士。戴维斯博士的科研生涯始于对面孔辨识能力和目击者辨认的研究。自2011年以来，他主要致力于了解超级面孔辨识者在此领域的非凡能力。他开发了筛查测试，以更好地识别超级面孔辨识者，并与世界各地的警察局及其他机构合作，探讨超级面孔辨识者如何为安保工作做出贡献。
Our second guest is Kelly Despera. Ms. Despera has always had an extraordinary ability to recognize and remember faces, but she didn't know that she was a super recognizer until about four years ago, when she took the online super recognizer screening test and received the highest score that researchers had ever seen. Today she works for a company called Super Recognizers International, which trains and employs Super Recognizers to assist with everything from murder investigations to security at sporting events. Thank you both for joining us today. Hi, Kim. Nice to see you.
我们的第二位嘉宾是凯利·德斯佩拉。德斯佩拉女士一直拥有非凡的面孔辨识和记忆能力，但她直到大约四年前参加了在线超级面孔辨识者筛查测试，并获得了研究人员见过的最高分时，才知道自己是一名超级面孔辨识者。今天，她供职于一家名为“超级面孔辨识者国际”的公司，该公司培训并雇用超级面孔辨识者来协助处理从谋杀案调查到体育赛事安保等各项事务。非常感谢二位今天做客我们的节目。嗨，金。很高兴见到你。
Hello. Thank you very much for inviting us. It's very exciting. All right. So we're going to go with first names here just to keep it on a little informal basis. So, Josh, let's start with you. How do you identify and define a super recogniser and how good does someone have to be at recognising faces to qualify? On the whole, we've sort of set a rather arbitrary standard for super recognition that people should be able, to be in the top 2% of the population, achieving scores, should I say, on four primary criteria. Short-term face memory, long-term face memory, simultaneous face matching, which is the art of passport officers checking identity documents that the person in front of them is the person they say they are, and also spotting faces in a crowd. And we expect super recognises to be in the
你好。非常感谢邀请我们。这让人非常兴奋。好的。为了保持轻松的氛围，我们接下来直呼其名。那么，乔希，我们先从你开始。你如何识别和定义一个超级面孔辨识者？一个人必须具备多强的面孔辨识能力才能符合资格？总的来说，我们为超级辨识设定了一个相当随的标准，即人们应该能够进入人口的前2%，并且在四个主要标准上取得相应的分数。这四个标准是：短期面孔记忆、长期面孔记忆、同时面孔匹配（也就是护照官员检查身份证件以确认面前的人就是其所声称的人的艺术），以及在人群中发现面孔。我们期望超级辨识者在这
top 2% on all four criteria. Kelly, did you always know this was something that you were very, very good at? How did you first recognize that you had an extraordinary ability that everybody else didn't have? I had no idea. I had no idea that I was doing anything different to anybody else. So I imagined that people could recognize a person they hadn't seen for 30 or years that they'd only seen for a little while or just noticed someone from a small part of their face. It's just, yeah, I thought everyone was doing the same thing. And I was reading a crime novel, and in that novel, the story tells of the detective who calls on the Super Recogniser unit at Scotland Yard to send them some help. So I googled the term Super Recogniser and found one of
四个标准上都进入前2%。凯利，你一直都知道自己在这方面非常非常厉害吗？你是如何第一次意识到自己拥有别人所没有的非凡能力的？我完全不知道。我压根不知道自己做的事和别人有什么不同。所以我一直以为所有人都能认出一个30多年没见、当时只见过一会儿的人，或者仅凭脸部一小部分就能认出某人。就是这样，对，我以为大家都在做同样的事。当时我正在读一本犯罪小说，书里讲述了一个侦探请苏格兰场的超级辨识小组派人支援的故事。于是我谷歌搜索了“超级辨识者”这个词，找到了乔希的一项
Josh's tests, did the test, and the rest is history. So yes, I had no idea at all that I had this skill, and it turns out that it was something quite rare. And do you have any examples of, from your daily lifetimes that you've recognized somebody from long ago or totally out of context? I suppose there's two ways to explain it. One is somebody you know vaguely and somebody you don't know. And that's the really big one is the don't know person. But the example I would give is I was in a local town at a parade. And I just, in a big crowd, I happened to look over my shoulder and I saw a girl stood a few people behind me.
测试，做了测试，然后历史就被改写了。所以，是的，我完全不知道自己有这项技能，结果证明这是一种相当罕见的能力。你有没有在日常生活中认出很久以前的人或完全在毫无关联的语境下认出某人的例子？我想这可以用两种情况来解释。一种是你隐约认识的人，另一种是你完全不认识的人。最厉害的当属不认识的人。不过我要举的例子是，我在当地小镇的一个游行上。当时人山人海，我偶然转过头去，看到几个身后的队列里站着一个女孩。
And I just glimpsed her for a split second. And in that split second, I knew that that was Amber, who is the sister of a girl I went to kindergarten with 36 years prior. And she wasn't even my friend. She was my friend's sister, who I think I saw a couple of times when I went around to play at my friend's house. But it was just that split second. And I worked out that it was 36 years since I would have last saw her.
我只匆匆瞥了她一眼。就在那电光石火的一瞬间，我知道那是安贝尔，她是我36年前读幼儿园时一个女同学的姐姐。她甚至不是我的朋友。她是我朋友的姐姐，我大概只去朋友家玩的时候见过她几次。但真的就只是那一瞬间。我算了一下，距离我上次见到她已经过去36年了。
But again, at the time, I didn't know I was doing anything weird. I thought that was normal. And I would bound up to people and say, oh, my goodness. I can't believe it. It's hit, hi, how are you doing? And they would just look at me blankly as I was a complete loon. And I would say, it's me, it's Kelly, and thinking, you know, they've clearly forgotten who I am and I'm a forgettable type of person. But I guess, I guess an example of the way a super recogniser works that illustrates it best is I was given the image of a known predator that we were looking for at a sporting event.
但同样，当时我并不知道自己在做什么奇怪的事。我以为这很正常。我会兴冲冲地跑上去对人说：“哦，天哪。我真不敢相信。是你，嗨，最近怎么样？”而他们只会一脸茫然地看着我，仿佛我是个彻底的疯子。然后我会说：“是我，我是凯利”，心想（你知道的），他们显然已经把我忘得精光，而我是那种毫无存在感的人。不过我想，最能说明超级辨识者工作方式的一个例子是：在一次体育赛事中，我拿到了一张我们正在搜寻的已知不法分子的照片。
I looked his face for maybe two or three seconds and that imprinted it in my mind and I went into the crowd. And on that day in that crowd, there were 42,000 people there and I was able to find him and alert security to his presence there. So that's what a super recogniser can do. That just sounds miraculous. So Josh, what do we know about how super recognizers are able to do this? Do we have clues from brain imaging research or other studies? We think, first of all, that's probably inherited. At least face recognition ability seems to have a genetic component because if you run twin studies, as some researchers have done, they find that identical twins tend to score far more similarly on face recognition tests than non-identical twins. And as of course identical twins share 100% of their genes and non-identical twins share less of their genes. gene, therefore that seems to illustrate that we do have a genetic component. And in fact,
我看了他的脸大概两三秒钟，这就在我脑海里留下了深刻印象，随后我走进了人群。那天那个人群里有42,000人，而我认出了他并提醒安保人员他就在现场。这就是超级辨识者能做到的事。这听起来简直像个奇迹。那么，乔希，对于超级辨识者是如何做到这一点的，我们了解多少？我们能否从脑成像研究或其他研究中找到线索？首先，我们认为这很可能是遗传的。因为正如一些研究人员所做的那样，如果你进行双胞胎研究，你会发现同卵双胞胎在面孔辨识测试中的得分往往比异卵双胞胎要相似得多。当然，同卵双胞胎共享100%的基因，而异卵双胞胎共享的基因则较少。基因，因此这似乎表明我们确实具有遗传因素。事实上，
we have done some parents and child testing, and we do find a correlation between a parent's ability and their child's ability and super recognisers score slightly higher than, sorry, the children of super recognises tend to score higher than the children of controls. So there's that genetic link. there does seem to be from face recognition something to do with your experiences as well. And a very obvious example here is that most people are better at recognising faces of their own ethnicity than of other faces. And it seems to happen with ages versus other ages as well. And we've found that we had one super recogniser in a study in particular.
我们做过一些父母和孩子的测试，确实发现父母的能力与孩子的能力之间存在相关性，而且超级辨识者的孩子们的得分略高于——抱歉，超级辨识者的孩子们往往比对照组的孩子们得分更高。所以确实存在这种遗传联系。不过，从面孔辨识来看，这似乎也与你的经历有关。一个非常明显的例子是，大多数人识别自己族裔面孔的能力要好于识别其他族裔面孔。年龄与其他年龄之间似乎也存在这种情况。我们发现，在某项研究中，有一位超级辨识者——
we asked super recognisers to recognise baby faces. It's sort of the opposite to what Kelly is describing. And we found that adult super recognisers were better than controls at recognising baby faces. But in our sample, we coincidentally had a doctor who worked with babies all the time. And her scores were the only ones who were actually higher on the baby face test than the adult face test because she was used to faces. So there is something driving it with experience as well. And that seems to be the key factors. Kelly, you talked about recognizing somebody you hadn't seen since kindergarten, who clearly was now an adult.
我们要求超级辨识者识别婴儿的面孔。这有点像凯利所描述的相反情况。我们发现成年超级辨识者在识别婴儿面孔方面比对照组表现得更好。但在我们的样本中，我们碰巧有一位经常和婴儿打交道的医生。她的得分是唯一一个在婴儿面孔测试中的得分实际上高于成年面孔测试的，因为她习惯了看婴儿的脸。所以经历也在其中起到了驱动作用。这似乎是关键因素。凯利，你刚才提到认出了一个自幼儿园以来就没见过、现在显然已经成人的面孔。
Is that common for you that you know somebody as a child and you see them 35 years later? you know it's the same person, even though they've radically changed? Yeah, it appears that time doesn't seem to really play a part in this. The facial features must say similar enough for me to be able to recognize it, but there can be 20, 30 more than that years apart, or they were a child, now they're an adult, and I can still tell them apart. So, yeah, I can also recognize people who've drastically changed their appearance, so they might have facial hair, completely different hair style, different hair colour. So it seems like
你经常能通过认出一个小时候认识的人，在35年后认出他们，即使他们的外貌已经发生了脱胎换骨的变化吗？是的，时间似乎在这个过程中并不起什么作用。面部特征一定足够保持相似，以便我能认出他们，但时间可以间隔20年、30年甚至更久，或者他们从一个孩子长成成年人，我依然能把他们认出来。所以，是的，我还能认出外貌发生巨大变化的人，比如他们可能留了面部毛发、换了完全不同的发型、染了不同的发色。所以看起来
the facial features will always remain imprinted and I can pick them up. Can I add to that? I mean, the very first research on super recognisers used before they were famous test. This was by researchers in Harvard. And effectively, they showed famous people's photographs when they were children. And The super recognisers are always far better at doing that type of test. We quite often use that as a demonstration when I'm giving talks to super recognises or other people. And you'll show, I don't know, a child image of, say, Britney Spears. And the super recognises, they've almost got their hands up almost immediately identifying Brittany far quicker than everybody else.
面部特征总是会留在记忆中，我能把他们挑出来。我能补充一点吗？我的意思是，对超级辨识者的最初研究使用的是他们成名之前的测试。这是哈佛大学的研究人员做的。实际上，他们展示了名人小时候的照片。而超级辨识者在做这类测试时总是要好得多。当我给超级辨识者或其他任何人做演讲时，我们经常用这个来作演示。你会展示，比如说，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯的儿童照片。而超级辨识者几乎立刻就能举手认出布兰妮，比其他人快得多。
And, you know, people with average ability quite often just sit there going, no one can do this because it's impossible. So something is happening. And we've used an unfamiliar type of project as well. Well, you'll show an adult face with three babies. One of them is the adult. And super recognisers tend to score higher on that one. And yet they've never met the babies or the adults. So, Kelly, are you aware of what you.
你知道的，具备平均能力的人往往只是坐在那里说：“没人能做到这一点，因为这不可能。”所以一定有什么机制在起作用。我们还使用了不熟悉类型的项目。你可以展示一张成人的脸和三个婴儿。其中一个是那个成人的婴儿期。超级辨识者在这类测试中往往得分更高。然而他们从未见过那些婴儿或成年人。那么，凯利，当你看着一张脸时，你知道自己在看什么吗？
you're looking at when you look at a face? Do you focus on anything in specific or you just get like a boom image of the whole face? Yeah, the latter. I'm not looking at details. I just know. It's a split second. It's a decision that just pops into my head. So yeah, I don't know how the science works and Josh might be able to elaborate or I think they're still looking into it, right, Josh? But I feel like I see the whole. I see the shape. I see a shape. So I can get people from the backs of their heads too. So that tells me that I'm seeing a shape of someone rather than the facial features. And also I can tell them from just a small part of their face or if they're wearing a mask, I can tell them from their eyes. So the masks haven't caused a problem in identifying people.
你专注于任何具体的东西，还是仅仅得到整张脸的一个立体图像？是的，是后者。我没有看细节。我就是知道。那只是电光石火的一瞬间。那是一个直接蹦进我脑海的决定。所以，是的，我不知道科学原理是如何运作的，乔希也许能详细说明，或者我想他们仍在研究中，对吧，乔希？但我感觉我看到的是整体。我看到的是轮廓。我能看到一个轮廓。所以我甚至能从人们的脑后认出他们。这告诉我，我看到的是某个人的整体轮廓，而不是面部特征。此外，我还可以仅从他们脸部的一小部分，或者如果他们戴着口罩，我能从他们的眼睛认出他们。所以口罩并没有给识别带来问题。
So throughout the pandemic, it hasn't impaired your ability to basically do your job, right? No. No, it's not as easy. Don't get me wrong. But there's still that instantaneous recognition if you do see the person you're looking for. I could add to that that we have done research. We found super recognisers were better than controls at recognising faces with face masks on, whether they were familiar with them or unfamiliar. And something else that Kelly said that strikes me was that we have done research using EEG as well, measuring brain activity. And we also found that super recognisers seem to have a greater spike of activity very early in face processing
所以在整个疫情期间，这并没有削弱你基本完成工作能力，对吗？没有。没有，虽然没那么容易，别误会我的意思。但如果你看到了你在寻找的人，依然会有那种瞬间的认出。我可以补充的是，我们做过研究。我们发现超级辨识者在识别戴口罩的面孔方面比对照组表现得更好，无论这些面孔是他们熟悉的还是陌生的。凯利所说的另一件事让我印象深刻，那就是我们还使用脑电图（EEG）测量脑活动进行了研究。我们还发现，与对照组相比，当超级辨识者看到熟悉的面孔时，
when they saw a face that was familiar to them in comparison to controls. And that might link to what Kelly said about sort of instantaneously being able to recognize as someone familiar to them as well. But that does need some replication. It was published in Cortex, which is quite a nice journal to get published in. So you know which part of the brain or parts of the brain are involved in recognition at this point, Josh? That particular research was EEG, which measures activity. And if you like, it's not very good at geographically mapping the areas in the brain that is active at the time.
他们在面孔加工的极早期似乎有更大的脑电活动峰值。这可能与凯利所说的那种能够瞬间认出熟悉之人的说法有关。但这还需要一些重复验证。该研究发表在《Cortex》上，这是一本很不错的期刊。那么，乔希，你知道大脑的哪个部分或哪些部分参与了此时的识别吗？那项特定的研究使用的是脑电图，它测量的是活动。如果你愿意的话，它不太擅长在地理上标定当时活跃的大脑区域。
But other people have done fMRI studies, which is far more accurate. at measuring the brain. And there's an area that seems to be associated with face recognition called the fusiform gyrus. And when that area gets damaged, for instance, people often develop prosopagnosia as you introduce the topic and become face blind. So there is a lot of evidence from fMRI as well. It's more active when people are viewing faces.
但其他人做过功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）研究，这在测量大脑方面要准确得多。有一个似乎与面孔辨识相关的区域叫做梭状回（fusiform gyrus）。当这个区域受损时，例如，正如你引出的话题那样，人们经常会患上脸盲症（prosopagnosia）并失去面孔辨识能力。因此，来自fMRI的证据也很多。当人们观看面孔时，该区域更加活跃。
So, Kelly, I have to ask you a question on behalf of our producer. Louer Lee Wynerman, who is the mother of identical twins. Do identical twins look different to you all the time? Completely. Yeah, I have identical twins in my family. And I spent a lot of time with them when they were younger. So when they were toddlers. And I saw them as two completely separate faces. And again, I wish I'd have known why I was seeing that at the time. But no, they just, again, in a glimpse or a side view, they would just, I would know. which one was Kirsty and which one was Lacey. And yeah, although I fully appreciate how similar they look, obviously, but I can completely tell them apart. They're just, the differences are glaringly obvious to me. Well, let me ask you both, this one,
所以，凯利，我必须代表我们的制片人路易·李·温曼（Louer Lee Wynerman）问你一个问题，她是同卵双胞胎的母亲。同卵双胞胎在你看来无时无刻都长得不一样吗？完全不一样。是的，我家里有同卵双胞胎。在他们小的时候，我花了很多时间陪他们。所以当他们还是幼儿的时候。在我眼里，他们是两张完全不同的脸。再次说明，我希望当时我知道为什么自己会看到这种区别。不过，不，他们就是——同样，只需匆鸿一瞥或从侧面看，我就会知道
do super recognisers have better than average memory in any other areas of life? Well, I can answer that. We have used object memory tests and some other sort of visual processing tests, and they tend to be slightly better than controls at these other tests, suggesting that they do have superior memory for visual things in general, but actually the differences between controls and super recognises far greater when it comes to faces. And perhaps we found voices as well. We've done some recent research, finding that they tend to be slightly better at voices, which might suggest that it's something about human identification, human recognition, rather than purely face recognition.
哪个是科斯蒂，哪个是莱西。是的，尽管我完全理解他们看起来有多么相似，但我的确能完全把他们区分开来。对我来说，他们之间的差异是显而易见的。好吧，我想问你们两个这个问题：超级辨识者在生活中的其他领域是否拥有高于平均水平的记忆力？嗯，我可以回答这个问题。我们使用过物体记忆测试和其他一些视觉处理测试，他们在这些其他测试中的表现往往略好于对照组，这表明他们在总体上对视觉事物的记忆力确实更优异，但实际上，当涉及到面孔时，对照组与超级辨识者之间的差距要大得多。或许我们在声音方面也有所发现。我们最近的一些研究发现，他们在声音方面往往也略好一些，这可能表明这关乎人类的辨识、人类的认知，而不仅仅是纯粹的面孔辨识。
Kelly's always described her ability to recognize people by other things from the back of the head sometimes. So it's not just about the face. And you just mentioned voice recognition as well. Is that another burgeoning area of research right now that people can just tell who someone is based on hearing their voice? Yeah. So I have a PhD student, Ryan Jenkins, who's been researching voice recognition. We find that people with super recognition ability for faces tend to be better at voices as well, but it's not 100% by any means. It's a small proportion. So that's research is ongoing. One of the things is developing tests to actually measure this ability is always a bit harder than it perhaps you imagine when you start down this PhD progress. So a few minutes ago,
凯利一直描述她通过其他特征来辨认人的能力，有时甚至通过后脑勺。所以这不仅关乎面孔。你刚才也提到了声音辨识。这是否是当前另一个蓬勃发展的研究领域，即人们仅凭听到声音就能分辨出某是谁？是的。我的博士生瑞安·詹金斯（Ryan Jenkins）一直在研究声音辨识。我们发现，具备面孔超级辨识能力的人在辨别声音方面往往也更强，但绝不是100%. 这只是一个小比例。所以这项研究仍在进行中。其中一件事就是，开发测试来实际衡量这种能力，往往比你在刚开始攻读博士学位时想象的要困难一些。几分钟前，
Josh mentioned that there's a genetic component to this. So, Kelly, are there other people in your family who have this ability? I think that my mom, my mother might have it. So she's pulled some stunts that I think that would suggest that she found a phone, an iPhone on the floor in a public garden. And she picked it up and it was somebody was calling it and it showed the face of the person calling and she knew she'd just walk past that person. So she took it back to them. So I said, hmm, mom, I think maybe something's going on here. So yeah, I would say she's a high,
乔希提到这其中有遗传因素。那么，凯利，你的家里有其他人也有这种能力吗？我觉得我妈妈——我母亲可能也有。她做过的一些事让我觉得这或许有所暗示。她在公共花园的地上捡到了一部iPhone。她把它捡起来，正有人在打电话，屏幕上显示着来电者的脸，她知道自己刚才正好从那个人身边走过。于是她把手机送回给了失主。所以我说：“嗯，妈妈，我觉得这里面可能有点名堂。”所以，是的，可以说她有很高的一
she's got a high potential there. So she hasn't taken the test? She hasn't. She's probably too scared to fail. I'm going to encourage her. So is facial recognition ability something you can train yourself to do or even to just get better at? Some researchers have tried to teach people to be better at face recognition, in particular in perhaps the sort of identity verification role such as passport officers, because that's so important. So perhaps you can improve slightly the ability to perhaps do a face matching task by asking people to focus on features or other aspects of the face, it doesn't seem to improve
个潜力。所以她还没做过测试？她还没做。她大概是太害怕失败了。我要鼓励她一下。那么，面孔辨识能力是你可以通过训练自己去做，甚至只是为了做得更好的一种能力吗？一些研究人员曾试图教人们更好地进行面孔辨识，特别是可能在身份验证角色中，比如护照官员，因为这太重要了。所以或许你可以通过要求人们专注于面孔的特征或其他方面，来稍微提高执行面孔匹配任务的能力，但这似乎并不能普遍提高
face recognition in general, this type of training scheme. So I'm afraid your ability seems to peak at about 30 years of age, keeps improving beyond the teenage years, but then there's a long, unfortunate, slow decline from that point on. Well, then perhaps it's lucky, Kelly, that you also are a professional photographer, which is also a visual field. Do you feel that it's linked in any way to your super recognising ability? And do you only take portraits? No, I do all sorts of commercial photography. So I don't think it's linked, to be honest with you.
面孔辨识能力——这种类型的训练计划。所以恐怕你的能力似乎在大约30岁时达到顶峰，在十几岁之后会继续提高，但从那以后就会经历一个漫长、不幸而缓慢的衰退期。好吧，凯利，也许你同时也是一名职业摄影师，这也是一个视觉领域，这可以说是你的幸运。你觉得这和你的超级辨识能力有什么联系吗？你只拍肖像吗？不，我从事各种商业摄影。老实说，我不认为这有什么联系。
There's all sorts of different people from different walks of life, different skills that are super recognises. And I can't see a pattern there. I put a lot of attention to detail in my work. and I am meticulous, and that helps with my job, but I don't see a link. I don't see a link there. Well, speaking of jobs, your other job, as I mentioned in the intro, was that you work for Super Recognizers International doing investigative and security identification work. What kind of organizations do you work with, and what do you do for them on an average day?
各行各业形形色色的人、拥有各种不同技能的人都可能是超级辨识者。我看不到其中的规律。我在工作中投入了大量的对细节的关注，而且我一丝不苟，这有助于我的工作，但我看不出有什么联系。我看不到任何联系。好吧，说到工作，正如我在引言中提到的，你的另一份工作是为“超级辨识者国际”公司工作，从事调查和安保辨识工作。你与哪些类型的组织合作？在平常的一天里，你为他们做什么？
Yeah, I work for law enforcement agencies, police departments, security, private security companies, and we do all sorts of things from, as you mentioned, murder investigations, assault investigations, through to live events where we're on foot doing, you know, covert operations, looking for people in crowds. So there's a variety of ways in which we can apply the skill. We can produce facial comparison reports for people who are trying to prove the identity of somebody. So it's very varied
是的，我与执法机构、警察局、安保、私人安保公司合作，我们做各种各样的事情，正如你所提到的，从谋杀案调查、袭击案调查，到我们在现场步行的现场活动——执行秘密行动，在人群中寻找目标。所以我们可以通过多种方式应用这项技能。我们可以为试图证明某人身份的人制作面孔比对报告。所以这是非常多样化的。
And I'm also working on quite quick moving investigations such as missing people, trafficked and exploited children. I work for the NCPTF, which is the National Child Protection Task Force over in America there, who do an amazing job investigating missing children and rescuing them. They're amazing as a global force that are volunteering together to help. and I'm one of their what they'd like to call mutants. They have a team of all sorts of different skills and I'm proud to say I'm one of their mutants. So yeah, that's the sort of thing we're doing.
我也在参与一些节奏相当快的调查，例如失踪人口、被贩运和遭受剥削的儿童。我为美国的国家儿童保护工作组（NCPTF）工作，他们在调查失踪儿童和营救儿童方面做着了不起的工作。作为一个志愿联合起来提供帮助的全球力量，他们太棒了。我是他们喜欢称之为“变种人”的其中一员。他们有一个拥有各种不同技能的团队，我很自豪地说我是他们的变种人之一。所以，是的，这就是我们所做的事情。
And have you found missing children yourself? Yeah. That must be very, very satisfying. It is. I'm able to be given some faces of children that we know are being exploited. We have the predator as well. I had a case where we had a predator and two children linked together. I was able to find links to them online and we picked them up around six hours after I identified them.
你亲自找到过失踪儿童吗？找到过。那一定非常有成就感。确实如此。我能够获得一些我们知道正遭受剥削的儿童的面孔。我们也有不法分子。我曾遇到过一个案子，其中有一个不法分子和两个相互关联的儿童。我能够在线找到他们的线索，并在我辨认出他们大约六个小时后，我们就找到了他们。
So my leads will be given to the police department who are investigating that. So obviously I don't just say it's them, go get them. They will have to do a thorough investigation. So I'm just the lead. and then it saves them days, weeks, months of searching and trawling, I can get them results really quickly, then they can follow those leads. And in that case, it's six hours before they were, the kids were rescued and the predator was arrested.
所以我把线索交给正在调查此案的警察局。显然，我不会只是说“就是他们，去抓他们”。他们必须进行彻底的调查。所以我只是提供线索，然后这为他们节省了几天、几周、几个月的搜寻和排查时间，我可以非常迅速地为他们提供结果，然后他们就可以顺藤摸瓜。在这种情况下，在孩子们被解救、不法分子被捕之前，仅仅过去了六个小时。
So, yeah, we're getting some brilliant results. We've had some great results in murder investigations too, where my evidence has helped to narrow down timelines for the police and improve premeditation. So I can create a nice package of evidence for the prosecution. In recent years, we've heard a lot about artificial intelligence, facial identification algorithms, and how they're being used in everything from social media to policing. Well, there are obviously some ethical and legal questions around this, but just as a purely practical question, are super recognizers as good as AI algorithms, or are they better?
所以，是的，我们取得了出色的成果。我们在谋杀案调查中也取得了很棒的成果，我的证据帮助警方缩小了时间范围，并完善了对预谋的认定。因此，我可以为公诉方整理出一套漂亮的证据包。近年来，我们听到了很多关于人工智能、面孔辨识算法以及它们如何被应用于从社交媒体到警务工作的方方面面的信息。虽然这周围显然存在一些伦理和法律问题，但仅从纯粹的实用角度来看，超级辨识者和AI算法一样优秀，还是说他们更好？
So the last big piece of research really on this was done in the United States. and they recruited Super Recognizers, controls, also forensic facial analysts, and the best algorithms at the time, as identified by the National Institute of Science and Technology in the USA. And they found that the Super Recognizer was operating at the same level as the best algorithms and far better than controls. But what they also found, which I think is really key here, is that actually if you combined the decision-making of a super-recognizer with an algorithm, accuracy was even higher. And one of the reasons is because algorithms make mistakes that a human would never make,
所以关于这一点，真正的大型最新研究是在美国进行的。他们招募了超级辨识者、对照组，还有法医面孔分析师，以及美国国家标准与技术研究院（NIST）认定的当时最好的算法。他们发现超级辨识者的运作水平与最好的算法不相上下，而且远超对照组。但他们还发现了一点，我认为这才是真正的关键所在：实际上，如果你将超级辨识者的决策与算法结合起来，准确率会更高。原因之一是算法会犯人类绝不会犯的错误，
and humans make mistakes that an algorithm probably wouldn't make. So therefore, you're removing those errors that are probably unique to both and getting better outcomes. Does AI have the ability that Kelly described, which is she can, can tell people from seeing the backs of their heads? Almost certainly not. I don't think because AI has to be trained with images for it to be able to perform these tasks. And I don't think there are any databases of faces from the back of the head to train AI.
而人类则会犯算法可能不会犯的错误。因此，你消除了那些可能对双方而言都独有的错误，从而获得了更好的结果。AI具备凯利所描述的那种能力吗？即她能从后脑勺认出人？几乎肯定没有。我不认为如此，因为AI必须用图像进行训练才能执行这些任务。而且我认为不存在从后脑勺拍摄的面孔数据库来训练AI。
So that's how it works. You have to sort of throw into the mix hundreds, if not thousands of faces for AI to be most effective, a bit like humans. And if you haven't got those images, then humans are going to beat AI every single time. And we can also deal with really low quality images, you know, really pixelated images aren't going to deter us. And also, you know, like I said, masks, facial hair, bits and pieces that might throw an algorithm off.
这就是它的工作原理。为了让AI发挥最大效用，你必须把成百上千张面孔——有点像人类——投入其中。如果你没有这些图像，那么人类每一次都会战胜AI。而且我们还能处理非常低质量的图像，你知道，真正像素化的图像不会阻碍我们。而且，正如我所说，口罩、面部毛发、可能让算法糊涂的零星碎片，
We kind of override those. So I think I am a great advocate of facial recognition software and I enjoy working with it. I get some of my best results when I team up with guys that use. facial recognition software. So I think putting the two of us together makes a superpower. So is it your view that people who check passports, say, in customs, should we be testing people for their facial recognition ability before they get jobs like this? Absolutely. And they do in some countries. You would never want someone with face blindness, prosopagnosia being a passport officer because they just could not do the job. I'm not necessarily
我们都能忽略。所以我绝对是面孔辨识软件的大力倡导者，我也很喜欢与它合作。当我与使用面孔辨识软件的伙伴们组队时，我能取得最好的成果。所以我认为把我们两个结合在一起会产生一种超能力。那么在你看来，比如说海关的护照检查员，我们在让他们担任这类工作之前，是否应该测试他们的面孔辨识能力？绝对应该。有些国家就是这么做的。你绝不会希望一个有脸盲症、患有面孔辨识障碍的人成为护照官员，因为他们根本无法胜任这项工作。我不一定
sure that you need super recognisers for that job, but what you want is people who have above average abilities in those sorts of roles, because they're far more likely to make a correct identification, but they're also far more likely not to make a wrong identification than people with average or lower ability. That's key as well. Kelly, is a company that you work for, advocate for this? I mean, do you consult to, you know, operations that maybe could use some sort of a test for their employees? Absolutely. We team up with lots of different companies to assist.
确信这类工作需要超级辨识者，但你想要的是在这些职位上具备高于平均能力的人，因为他们更有可能做出正确的辨识，而且与平均能力或较低能力的人相比，他们也更有可能不做出错误的辨识。这也是关键所在。凯利，你供职的公司是否倡导这一点？我的意思是，你们是否会向可能为员工使用某种测试的机构提供咨询？绝对的。我们与许多不同的公司组队提供协助。
We work for a company that do assess passport photographs and ID photos. So, yeah, it's definitely something we can apply and help with. And we do identify super recognisers through the testing and then we put them through our own training courses, which we'll teach them all about the law surrounding image use. It will enhance their skills with behaviour analysis as well if we're actually out and about. So we can enhance skills around super recognition too to make a really rounded super recognises that's able to go out into the world and use their skill for good.
我们为一家评估护照照片和身份证照片的公司工作。所以，这绝对是我们可以应用和协助的领域。我们确实通过测试来识别超级辨识者，然后让他们接受我们自己的培训课程，课程将教给他们关于图像使用法律的一切知识。如果我们实际走上街头，它还将通过行为分析来增强他们的技能。因此，我们还可以增强围绕超级辨识的技能，打造一个真正的全能超级辨识者，让他们能够走向世界，将自己的技能用于正义事业。
So some of our listeners might not be aware that in your country and you're both in England, that there are closed circuit TVs pretty much everywhere, right? You folks are on camera all the time. It's a little different from the U.S. where, you know, we're very sort of hinky about that concept. Are there ethical issues surrounding what it is that you do, for example, trying to find criminals? I mean, do people in England feel like their privacy has been invaded? So they do worry about privacy in terms of computerized face recognition systems, definitely. But I don't think anybody worries about super-recognized.
所以我们的一些听众可能不知道，在你们的国家（你们都在英格兰），几乎到处都是闭路电视，对吧？你们随时都在摄像头监控之下。这与美国有点不同，在美国，你知道的，我们对这个概念非常敏感。你们所做的事情周围是否存在伦理问题，例如试图寻找罪犯？我的意思是，英国人觉得自己的隐私受到侵犯了吗？所以在计算机面孔辨识系统方面，他们确实担心隐私问题，这是肯定的。但我认为没有人会担心超级辨识。
It's because, if you like, they epitomise what an old-fashioned police officer should be able to do. They know all the criminals. You see it on cop shows. There's nothing strange about super recognises within policing identifying criminals and people like that. Everyone expects it. It's the algorithms they are more suspicious of, definitely. And it's a way of life for us being on camera. I would far rather that my whole country was covered in cameras.
这是因为，如果你愿意的话，他们完美体现了一个老派警察应该具备的能力。他们认识所有的罪犯。你在警匪片里就能看到。在警务工作中，超级辨识者识别罪犯之类的人并没有什么奇怪的。每个人都习以为常。他们更怀疑的绝对是算法。生活在摄像头下对我们来说已经是生活方式的一部分。我宁愿我的整个国家都布满摄像头，
And if something happens to me or one of my loved ones, that it's. going to get picked up and we've going to have some evidence to work from the number of cases that are solved through surveillance footage and, you know, come to a conclusion much quicker and more accurately because of that. I'm a strong believer that we should stick cameras everywhere and I certainly have them all over my house. I don't. For me personally, I'm protective of my privacy, but I do agree that in some areas you do want cameras. You want them in town. centers and airports and places like that, train stations, travel centers, and they should be scrutinized properly.
如果我和我的某个亲人发生点什么，它会被拍下来，我们会得到一些可以据此开展调查的证据。因为监控录像而侦破的案件数量众多，并且因此能够更快速、更准确地得出结论。我坚信我们应该到处安装摄像头，我家里肯定到处都是。我个人而言，我很珍视自己的隐私，但我确实同意在某些区域你确实需要摄像头。你希望它们在市中心、机场以及诸如此类的地方、火车站、交通枢纽出现，并且它们应该受到适当的审查。
So my understanding is that the cameras were installed because there was the thinking among law enforcement that they would be a deterrent, but it seems that they're not, that a lot of people will just blithely go about committing crimes because they figure there are tens and thousands and millions of these images. No one's ever going to find me. Do you feel that the public, at least in the UK, is aware of the fact that you have been able to crack a lot of cases? Yeah, I think it's been very important. The super-recognizer successes that have been in the media.
据我所知，安装摄像头的初衷是执法部门认为它们能起到威严作用，但事实似乎并非如此，许多人只是盲目地去犯罪，因为他们觉得有成千上万、数以百万计的这些图像。根本没人会找到我。你觉得公众（至少在英国）是否意识到你们已经能够破获很多案件？是的，我认为这非常重要。媒体对超级辨识者成功的报道起到了很大作用。
In fact, my PhD was on the way the faces are used in court for identification purposes. And at that time, they weren't at all. There was a lot of cameras around, and nobody was ever really looking at them. It's only later that they started properly scrutinising the images, making sure that they actually try and identify people committing crimes on camera. And that breeds success. More success, you get more criminals identified. And so much so that, you know, my work has transferred to other countries around the world,
事实上，我的博士论文研究的就是法庭上如何使用面孔进行辨识。在当时，法庭根本不使用这些。周围有很多摄像头，但从来没有人真正去看它们。直到后来，他们才开始真正仔细审查图像，确保他们确实尝试辨识在摄像头前犯罪的人。而这孕育了成功。更多的成功意味着能识别出更多的罪犯。以至于我的工作已经扩展到了世界上的其他国家，
especially at the moment we're identifying a lot of super recognises within German police forces, is super recognises in India working in identity verification, creating lots of jobs there for people working in sort of roles, checking identity documents for the government and other organisations. We're not really working in America, the USA, as of yet. But who knows? I'm on my way. I'm coming to get you. So, Kelly, I mean, it sounds like you really appreciate this, this, ability that you have, but I'm wondering if you ever feel that there are drawbacks. I mean, do people try to fool you? I don't see any drawbacks. I think it's a relief now I know I'm not
尤其是目前我们正在德国警察部队中识别出大量的超级辨识者，还有在印度的超级辨识者从事身份验证工作，为人们在政府和其他组织中从事检查身份证件等类似角色的工作创造了许多就业机会。我们目前还没有真正在美国开展工作。但谁知道呢？我正在路上了。我来抓你们了。所以，凯利，听起来你真的很感激这种能力，但我很好奇你是否曾觉得它也有缺点？我的意思是，人们会试图愚弄你吗？我看不出有什么缺点。我想现在我松了一口气，因为我知道自己没有
being stalked constantly because, of course, if you're walking around a shopping mall and you see the same person over and over again, you start to think, I'm being followed by this person, but essentially what's happening is I'm just recognizing the same person in the same shopping mall with me. There's nothing worse than that. So there aren't really any drawbacks. to be honest with you. It's very useful. It's a bit annoying for people who are around me when I keep telling them that that's the guy in the film 20 years ago that was an extra in Indiana Jones and the last crusade.
一直被跟踪——当然，如果你在购物中心走来走去，一遍又一遍地看到同一个人，你就会开始觉得，“我正在被这个人跟踪”，但本质上发生的事情是，我在同一个购物中心里认出了同一个人。没有什么比这更糟的了说实话，真的没有什么缺点。这非常有用。对于我周围的人来说可能有点烦人，当我不断告诉他们那个人就是20年那部电影里在《夺宝奇兵3》中跑龙套的演员时。
But no, it's, I embrace the skill. I'm so delighted that I can use it for good, that I'm seeing results that are meaning things to, it means something to families who have lost somebody or who are fighting for justice. So it's just an honour that I'm able to translate this skill into something. think useful for society. So Josh, last question. Where is the research going next? Well, that's a big question. We would like to do some more brain scanning research to try and understand exactly what's going on in super recognises brains. And then perhaps from that, we can
不过，不，我拥抱这项技能。我非常高兴能够将其用于正义事业，我看到的成果对那些失去了亲人或正在为正义而战的家庭来说意义重大。所以，能够将这种技能转化为对社会有用的东西，这简直是一种荣幸。那么，乔希，最后一个问题。接下来的研究方向是什么？嗯，这是一个宏大的问题。我们希望做更多的大脑扫描研究，以试图准确了解超级辨识者大脑中发生的事情。然后也许从中我们可以
understand how to better apply their skills in different workforces for whatever reason. because we don't really know where we might end up going in the future for the best use of super recognises. I'm probably more of an applied psychologist than a theoretical psychologist, more interested in seeing, you know, the practical aspects work like Kelly does. How else can we use Kelly's skills to, you know, help society in general? Are there places that we're missing the use of super recognition, Kelly? What are you looking for in your company? Are you expanding? Yeah, we certainly are.
了解如何更好地将他们的技能应用到不同的工作岗位中，无论出于何种原因。因为我们真的不知道未来我们会走向何方，以实现超级辨识者的最佳利用。我可能更像是一个应用心理学家，而不是理论心理学家，我对看到实用方面的工作成果（就像凯利那样）更感兴趣。我们还能如何利用凯利的技能来普遍帮助社会？我们有哪些地方忽视了超级辨识的应用吗，凯利？你在你的公司里寻找什么？你们在扩张吗？是的，我们确实在扩张。
Our passion is to help law enforcement. That's what we would like to do is to be able to go to law enforcement agencies and help them to identify super recognizers within their ranks because there are going to be hundreds of them. And it would be fantastic to think that we could identify them, helped train them to know their skill better and for them to be used within those police departments for the better. So that's our passion. Super recognises international would love to get out there and get amongst the law enforcement agencies to help them identify their own. That's where we
我们的激情是协助执法部门。我们想要做的是能够去到执法部门并帮助他们识别其队伍中的超级辨识者，因为他们队伍中肯定有数百人。如果能识别出他们，帮助他们更好地了解自己的技能，并让他们在警察局内部发挥更大作用，那就太棒了。所以这就是我们的激情所在。“超级辨识者国际”很乐意走出去，深入到执法部门中去，帮助他们识别出自己队伍中的人才。这就是我们
think we'd get the best results for society for. Well, I want to thank you both for joining us today. I think you're both doing extraordinarily important work and I thank you for it. Thank you very much. Thanks so much, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you can, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
我认为我们将为社会取得最好的结果。好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天能来参加我们的节目。我认为你们两位都在从事极其重要的工作，我对此表示感谢。非常感谢。非常感谢，金。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上收听往期的《心理学热线》节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您方便的话，请给我们留个好评。如果您对未来的播客有什么意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 与我们联系。
That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，邮箱是 @APA.org。《心理学热线》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。